publicans Senator John McCain of Arizona
was at the White House briefing
yesterday on North Korea he joins us now
from Capitol Hill
Senator McCain good morning morning
Charlie let me begin with this not only
with you at that briefing but you've had
a series of phone calls with the
president and you call the Syrian strike
a seminal moment in his presidency with
the cruise missile attacks in Syria not
just because of the damage but because
it sent a signal unlike previous years
that America will act what should the
North Koreans assume America will do I
think they should assume that the United
States will react forcefully but Charlie
there's a real complication and that is
along the DMZ they have artillery and
capabilities that would range Seoul
which is a city of 26 million people
that complicates things dramatically and
that's why a lot of the emphasis has got
to be on the only power that can
restrain them and that's China Chinese
have cut back on the coal supply but I
was not encouraged when the Chinese came
against our air defense system being in
place in South Korea the Chinese have to
really be made aware that this could
have a profound effect on our relations
with China because if this if this
exchange began the North Koreans very
likely could range Seoul exactly their
artillery and that that could be
catastrophic senator was there any
indication from that meeting at the
White House yesterday that military
action against North Korea is imminent
no but it is clear and I just totally
agree that that option can't be taken
off the table but it has to be the
absolute last option but when I say last
option that is when we are convinced
that North Korea has that capability to
launch a missile that could strike with
a nuclear weapon the west coast of the
United States this leader is not
rational he is not a person that we can
depend on
in a rational fashion what is the red
line button for acting because we
believe he has what you just said if it
were up to me Charlie I would probably
say a missile on on the launch pad that
we knew for sure had a nuclear weapon on
it I don't think we could wait till
launch we do have defensive capabilities
that can intercept missiles but to count
on that alone I think would be very
risky business look this is a very
serious issue very very serious and
there's nothing wrong with being called
down to the White House to talk about it
and it's also the product of three
previous administration presidents that
negotiated what would they lead was good
faith and turned out to be utterly false
while the North Koreans progressed in
their effort to acquire a missile in a
weapon one of your colleagues describes
a meeting yesterday as a dog and pony
show I'm wondering what your
characterization was did you learn
anything I didn't particularly because
you know this is my day to day business
but I think they learned about the
options that we have I think that the
attention we're paying to it but I don't
think they could expect a specific
course of action because as we just
described our courses of action are
would be dictated by North Korean
behavior senator one art one article
about you and president Trump said how
Trump came around to McCain on foreign
policy you had this dinner with him
along with Lindsey Graham what did you
learn about him what did you come away
with and did it change your mind about
Donald Trump well I've always had
respect for the office of the president
you know his States he was very cordial
and we had a lot of discussion on a lot
of issues I was pleased for example
yesterday that they did not move forward
with a red
education of the North American Free
Trade Agreement which known as NAFTA
which would have devastated the economy
of my state I don't think it's me I
think it's a person assuming the most
important job in the world and
understanding those responsibilities and
in the case of national security
surrounding himself with some of the
brightest people I've ever known and
I've known plenty of them Charlie more
longer than I've known you which goes
back to the Coolidge administration it
does well senator like Alden is a long
time well Senator McCain it's always
good to see you so bright and early in
the morning thank you so much we
appreciate it
thank you take care